[Music]
grown-ups three is it ever happening
well in a way it already did here's the
situation with adam sandler's grown-up
series and the sequel you can read right
now
oh somebody's in chamber not looking
good
for the most part you know exactly what
to expect from an adam sun the movie
sure every so often the comedian throws
us for a loop and gives the world an
uncut gems but most of santa's movies
involve him doing silly voices making
juvenile jokes and hanging out with a
bunch of his friends your mileage may
vary as to whether or not that's
entertaining some people love it and
some people don't find the sight of a
grown man on a bicycle vomiting to be
very funny at all
rocky balboa
grown-ups lands firmly in the juvenile
joke side of sandless filmography the
premise is perfectly sandler-esque it
follows a group of friends who haven't
seen each other in decades as they
reunite after their old basketball coach
passes away they decide to spend the 4th
of july weekend together catching up
reflecting on how much everything has
changed and getting into all sorts of
hijinks the film which brought together
sandler's buddies like chris rock david
spade kevin james and rob schneider
exceeded expectations at the box office
and pulled in enough money to warrant a
sequel 2013's grown-ups too to this day
it's sandler's only live-action movie to
receive a sequel which similarly made
plenty of cash at the box office so why
wasn't there a third one sadly for fans
of the first two grown-ups movies it
looks like this series is probably done
for
oh my god oh i don't know
when a comedy gets a sequel it tends to
happen fast so the fact that it's been
eight years since grown-ups 2 dropped in
theaters it's not looking likely that
grown-ups 3 will ever materialize by the
sounds of it the studio may have been
interested in a 3 call at some point
nick schwarzen who plays the bus driver
named nick in the grown-ups movies
explained in a 2020 interview with the
rich eisen show that sandler had
discussed the third movie with him but
the talk apparently didn't go anywhere
i've i've just heard everything with
grown-ups three he had talked about it
and then there was another script out
there
that wasn't approved swardson isn't the
only cast member who's been left in the
dark regarding a sequel maria bello who
plays sally in both grown-ups flicks was
asked about development on a sequel in
2016 while promoting the horror film
lights out as she told flickering myth
people have talked about it and we've
heard it might happen but i don't know
if there is a script i don't know what
there is but i hope so because boy it's
fun to work with those guys it's now
been six years since bellows interview
and there hasn't been much words since
that time about a sequel however if
you're really jonesing for some sandler
hijinks in your life there is a way that
you can read a third grown-ups movie
and then there was another one that just
went viral that somebody wrote that i
thought was a hoax but i guess it's real
and i guess the script's really good in
january 2020 the best show writer
producer tom sharpling unveiled on
twitter a spec script for a theoretical
grown-ups 3. well the script starts out
how you'd expect a director soon yells
cut and this revealed the actors sandler
and the gang are just playing characters
on a movie set they proceed to portray
exaggerated versions of their real life
selves but soon a killer goes on the
loose killing them one by one
miraculously the spec script maintains
the same tone as a goofy sunlight comedy
even with the killer at its center the
spec script blew up so much online that
sharpling was actually interviewed about
it by vulture where he discussed how his
screenplay manages to capture an
emotional pathos to the grown-up's
mythology he elaborated it's a grown-ups
movie that becomes a behind the scenes
movie that becomes a slasher film that
becomes this kind of meditation on aging
and the inevitability of irrelevance
that happens to everyone if you just
stay around then you lose at some point
nobody ever beats show business show
business beats everybody all in all the
idea for grown-ups 3 is awesome for an
exercise in metahuma
but it's probably too out there to ever
be made
still one can dream
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]